[Music]
[Laughter]
she's signed is
[Music]
is
this town ain't big enough for the two
of us i disagree i think it can be
community feel your hands you basic b
[Music]
louder with crowder studios protected
exclusively by walther there are plenty
of great firearm options out there all
we ask is that you try the walther and
let us know try it
you'll buy it see what i did there
it's a good gun
[Music]
um
it's called it's a really hard sip there
because
i had to take a sip and i also either
have a hiccup or a burp ah oh no i
apologize
should have prepared by the way one of
the funniest things i've ever seen this
is how you know you become a dad is a my
little uh my little daughter had the
hiccups and it terrified her
this face of terror
[Laughter]
[Music]
like a fish who just got a hook in it
whoa what is this oh no uh so anyway we
call those the hicka puppies don't worry
i'm not gonna bring out and bring out my
wallet pictures i'm not gonna
fold them out nothing wrong with that
now you just bring it up on your phone
yeah that's why hey here are some nice
memories of everything you did that
doesn't matter here's 5 000 pictures
yeah three days worth here get a chair i
added the sepia filter to make you feel
like it matters no one's ever going to
look back on anything
yes we just have evidence of every
second of our wasted life i cannot
imagine a president
in 30 years like yeah now this is your
sweet cherry 69 was your aim
yeah
is this is this you mooning the entire
cheerleading squad yeah yeah you
uploaded that okay yeah that is my ass
yes oh we noticed you used to tick-tock
as gender-fluid ziggy stardust that was
your name yeah okay yeah yeah well don't
wait up on those votes here's the dick
pics your grandpa used to send your
grandmother
oh were they officially dated
how'd you how did you meet grandma well
i sent dick pics to a good 1500 ladies
she was the lucky one and she was the
fondest of them all
she was very desperate yes she met her i
met her in a rest area she's a real
your grandma yes but back then she
was fat
thank you sir thank you uh thank you
luna i i realized i forgot
all right look just so you know uh we're
still waiting on info with the verdict
that's why i hope you guys have some
grace for us so yeah starting late um we
don't know when the verdict is going to
come in it's probably not going to come
in this morning whenever it does we are
going to stream just so you know so uh
may not be a long stream but when it
happens we'll be here unless it happens
on a sunday we'll give you the right
it's not going to happen because jesus
christ
no no but if it happens uh probably
tomorrow is my guess so
hopefully you guys understand you know
we did four hours several times this
week and uh so it's a four and a half
it's a little fluid four floor and a
half can you tell a little bit
so uh we're gonna be talking about quite
a bit today uh one thing
this is the problem and i talked about
this yesterday so you'll notice i have a
rifle here uh and we'll make sure that
unlike rust you guys can see the bolt
carrier has been removed uh i'll have
everyone check it uh there's no way to
not flag somebody at some point in the
studio so we will make sure that you see
that it's basically a skeleton but uh
no one has talked about this and i think
it's because the evidence wasn't
submitted to the defense and we've sort
of had to watch this in real time where
they have uh the prosecution now they're
spending way too much time on cal
written house having aimed his gun at
somebody if you look at the picture
which they provided which can't be
admissible in court and of course is a
violation of the legal processes we have
separate from that
i don't think it's physically possible
for kyle rittenhouse to do
what's been claimed of him
yeah
aiming with his left hand
putting a fire extinguisher down we're
going to go through the process then
while running
switching it to right and low
with
uh with his strap with his strap on his
rifle in all of a couple of seconds in
all of a couple of seconds oh maybe once
maybe once again i'm surprised the
defense didn't really uh put this up as
a defense so look i know i'm not a
lawyer but i'm doing better but
uh we are going to go through it today
it's just just what i think and you know
what i have uh the luxury of actually
having some time to rebut what the
prosecution presented because the
evidence was never uh submitted also
they uh they did uh completely warp that
file uh and change the aspect ratio so
it should be a misc mistrial with
prejudice period uh i just think that uh
the judge is uh letting them slow cook
yeah gotta slow cook the kurds
so we'll be talking about that in the q
and on shaman three and a half years in
prison for no violent crime so that's a
big deal
yep trespassing
i don't know i mean thank god they
didn't give me that when i used to
skateboard as a kid like hey are you
grinding my rail i'm going to sentence
you to three and a half years of being
pounded in the ass
back in the days
gate boards was used for skateboarding
yes and grounding my rail that's a
little different than what you're
actually doing yeah i know i mean it's a
problem it's wrong worth the escape is
not a crime like yeah but rape is but
not in the clink so enjoy that
that's the america we live in before we
get to all that of course gerald uh a g
morgan junior on twitter how are you i
am better than i should be after all of
the we've done nine hours in a while
live content this week yeah i know
already and i know and then since it's
like when people say what what does your
husband do mom's like
and i guess it's kind of a podcast like
oh so does my son
no whatever not same thing uh quarter
black garrett how are you good morning
what's going on i'm i'm feeling better
about about this a little bit good thing
i think you're right i think that the
judge he's kind of building a case in
his own mind going right he even said it
yesterday he's like day of reckoning man
i'm gonna i'm telling you if you go down
this route it's not gonna look good also
the rope day of reckoning is the name of
his favorite cheese yeah i was getting
it's the day of reckoning it's like a
sharp cheddar mixed with the farm at
trader joe's
delightful you know but the problem is i
do have a day of reckoning later out the
caboose
also my new metal band day of reckoning
yeah yeah
downtown
franklin sort of like you know metallica
meets uh neil young yeah yeah yeah
old man look at my life right you know
i'm a bit like you
uh and we also have neither you know
that voice that is uh he's on twitter at
landau dave dave lando he will be in
naples at off the hook
uh this weekend and then wednesday
before thanksgiving funny bone liberty
how are you sir ahoy i'm good yeah i not
really i slept like two hours well i
tossed and turned because i decided to
do kettlebell workout before bed oh well
that's very stupid isn't it yeah
it's bad and you should feel bad
it hurt my lower back
yeah well were you using the joe rogan
gorilla kettlebell no no i was using a
it was just a 35 pounder oh well there
you go yeah lights yeah it's not like i
mean that's pretty good it's not light
on your old backaroo no it's not see i
have the body it's just stretching it
doesn't work out even though i work out
i don't really stretch well no well dave
you can't do pelvic thrust with the
kettlebell that's not a workout look
we're going to let's stop it we're
talking about pelvic thrusts not
stretching well we're getting to the cue
non-shaman's prison center
yes we're not there yet i'm referring to
brian kettlebell yes
i am not a huge fan of kettlebells as uh
really won the cold war
we did yes i mean kettlebell our new
section something about a wall yeah
no that's a this is one of those things
like a trend like ah you know it's old
so it's better yeah uh maybe we changed
it because uh we had something better
yeah and a barbell is more effective in
a lot of ways kettlebells can be used
total gym you're right yeah total gym i
watch old exercise videos from the 50s
where it's just you standing in that
thing that goes around
to do this thing
and then you just smoke the whole time
well if you're sure like these are good
for me are you sure you should be doing
that with a chesterfield in your mouth
this is for my health boy all right
calisthenics four to five doctors
recommend lucky strikes yes
filter-less smooth pull follow the
science
and if luck strikes
i'm going to send a dick picture to your
ground which is very hard in this era i
have to take it go get it developed
it's like a guy with one of those powder
oh it's like almond milk
stay still
all right hold it hold it and then when
he's down he's like all right hold on
let me get the carrier pigeon
circumcised okay
so uh just so you know live monday
through thursday we are here if you
don't see the show on youtube 10 a.m
eastern just want to make sure that
we're clear about it unless we tell you
otherwise we tell you otherwise we
started late this week because we're
waiting for info on the on the jury on
the verdict and next week we won't
obviously have a show on thanksgiving uh
and i think we uh i'm not sure about
wednesday i think we have an interview
on wednesday okay
all right oh god okay so before
you know it's coming and you have to do
it just so you know again i don't i
don't use prompter maybe at some point i
should take a picture we can tweet it
out live yeah but i can comment this is
just like if you see what this is that
just like the highlights just says hey
this is the
this is the clip that's coming up yeah
hey this is going to get you and i just
looked at it and went shh
so it's a lucky day for us we have uh
our first look at the new black swan
trailer let's take a look
huh popping
whoa no no garrett i didn't say it she
said it i was just quoting what she said
i don't even know what that means
i i don't know i don't know exploding i
have no idea i just i mean i just hope
there's something
stronger between her and that foundation
than a thin layer of linoleum yeah i
just i just pray that that chandelier
never phantom of the operas yes
number 13 dead end drives yes
that would be a tragedy is what i'm
saying and i hope that would never
happen do you guys remember
i was terrified of that cat in that
commercial 13 dead and drive the board
anyway sorry after being here by the way
it would take a bigger chandelier dave
yeah no it would that's what i'm saying
it wouldn't i mean i'm gonna bounce off
we're gonna need a bigger chandelier
yeah you uh that's absolutely good yeah
don't give me that working-class
poppy you're gonna need a bigger
chandelier
look at this thing
i can't take her out look at doll's eyes
that is the least of her concerns
and when those dolls eyes roll over and
the ground shakes white so
ah sometimes dust falls from the ceiling
rafting
and does not come your valuables fall
off the shelves i tell you i think it's
an earthquake
it's not
it's a hunter
it's
[Laughter]
so my question to you is if you guys
have been following uh the the q and on
shaman thing and and where you line up
on that i think there's some universal
agreement that nobody likes him no yeah
i agree but i also don't think you
sentenced someone to
prison for over three years about three
and a half years yeah for admittedly
non-violent crimes that you have on
video really not a crime
i mean trespassing but they let them in
isn't it they look like buildings it is
a public building i don't know i don't
know the rules i mean because they
change
no they don't there are no well but do
you remember when they said i used to
think you were allowed to shoot a
pedophile when he was trying to rape you
but i'm murphy on the rulebook well no
if you brought the gun apparently you
forfeited your right to self-defense
it's like i'm playing backgammon and
they said no more dice well how do i
play the game isn't he vegan
he's yes the queue
is vegan well he is a shum yeah he's
been asking him in prison for the uh
he's like yeah is this farm to table
yeah well we're gonna they'll be farming
you on the table really quick
you're spending a wonderful morning
plowing the shaman fields if you thought
that hat was horny
wait till you meet your roommate yes
also we are going to use the hat
[Music]
really more of a message
i mean i understand if they put them
away for three and a half on personality
but on the crime i don't agree with it
at all he wouldn't he wouldn't be
getting uh very far in star search no
not at all they're gonna release him
after like three months from being
annoying
one and a half stars sinbad
two
[Laughter]
hey you all know how the q9 shaman be on
makeup and horns
nor mcdonald talked about that iman's on
star search where he's just like you
ever go to the store they don't got no
socks he's like this is never happening
i always have socks well yeah cause you
went to the chandelier store yeah that's
where you dance on hey man where's the
socks
it's your boy iced tea
[Laughter]
okay so again this is a fluid show
because we don't know what's coming in
here with the uh with the verdict if
anything is coming in we'll be updating
you live but we do have some other
things that we'll be talking about uh
and we of course will be on mug club
afterwards we found we've a lot of
people watching live on mud club lots
and lots of people have transferred over
from youtube to mug club and rumble and
just to be clear so you all know i don't
care where you watch i really don't care
where you watch now you can only watch
the full show on mug club right
but if you're watching the free i don't
care if it's on rumble if it's on
youtube i'd rather you guys support
rumble or mug club because you know um i
don't like uh commies yeah yeah you know
it's fair you do the wicked with the
kicks off because they don't like not a
big fan of the commies so yeah go to the
rumble you know you know so no offense
but it sounds like some commie
gobbledygook
yeah that one always gets me i'm nice
it's funny every time uh so uh this
weekend i've been paying so much
attention to rittenhouse that i forgot
that our former vice president is uh
still a thing
he uh has been promoting the victory of
the infrastructure bill and um
you know what i honestly want to see
from you comment below if this is
genuine if you can make sense of it
because usually i'm pretty good i mean
i've worked this is not a joke i've
worked with special needs people yeah
that's right yeah and i usually
interpret what they mean they want
i i don't know your guess is as good as
mine it's time for this week in biden
wait if you have a problem figuring out
whether you're for me or trump then you
ain't black someone's not on the blue
marker huh yeah the blue and i gotta
take orders
okay
conversations around those kitchen
tables that are both profound as they
are ordinary how do i cross a bridge in
the snowstorm
what happened no i
didn't think about it you know you're in
a situation what happens the bridge
collapses and there's a fire on the
other side it's going to take 10 miles
longer to get to the fire people can die
i mean this is real this is real stuff
wait if you have a problem figuring out
whether you're for me or trump then you
ain't black
it's real it's real that's real does
anyone know what he was saying uh no see
here's the thing
you drive across the bridge and it falls
down there's fire on the other side
what's going to do people going to die i
just watched 2012 with john cusack i'm a
little confused for those mayans
are they little people what do we say
this big eat hearts you can't put up
fires you can't eat it raw
listeria come on let's drive around is
it dwarf mine i don't know i don't know
small hearts are big hearts what is the
dinklage fella i talk to you with a full
heart
yeah like the grinch clear eyes very uh
full heart because i i i take pills to
keep him yeah lipitor
oh i shoot myself so
i don't here's the thing that i will say
remember how people didn't like donald
trump they would say he was a
a bad speaker and i would not say that
donald trump was the most eloquent
speaker however
the issues that people had with donald
trump and his speaking
were not accidental they were like
laser-guided fu missiles right excuse me
you're fake news you're fake news you
should be ashamed i don't take questions
from gays you're fake you know
that kind of people were like how could
he say that whereas biden is just it's
completely nonsensical it's just
huh are you a report
yeah what are we doing it's trying to
imagine if trump said that one person
would just raise their hand and go uh
so what 10 mile long bridge was there a
fire by what are you talking about right
exactly
shut up they spent two weeks on the fact
that he used a second hand to support a
glass of water yeah
yeah i mean yeah it's unbelievable you
are fake news we just brushed right over
biden falling down thrice donald trump
ran his wrist and biden sprained his
cerebellum and it's never come back
he has no idea what a bridge does
anymore and he runs our country well
somebody does that but it is it's water
hold it how does it it's holding up
i don't what people i don't know why he
chose to start with what you can't cross
a bridge it do you know how to cross the
bridge in winter
no he started with conversations around
the table does he think everybody's
talking about how to cross bridges yeah
they're like yeah they're pretty people
they're crossing the bridge in an rv
yeah so they're at the table wow it's
tin pools rolling studio
i don't know i have no i genuinely you
guys comment we'll take it in your
podcast sit around on mug club i will
take the best interpretation of what he
said i do not understand it at all
sit around the campfire just telling
tales of bridges how to collapse perhaps
i love it i mean no i hate it and the
marshmallows get uh toasted
yeah
but it's for real i don't know uh the
colombians bring my son trucks loads of
stuff for the bridge it's a snow
[Laughter]
he did it from across the room no stop
stop
stop hanging on my pants and telling
people it's me
so we're also screwed
[Laughter]
three more years all right here's my
really quickly just before explanation
do you think kyle written now is guilty
or not guilty what do you think they're
going to 95 chance not guilty okay 98
percent change i said just give me a
guilty but he did anyways i know you're
honest all right the computer wear
glasses
okay uh not guilty quarterback not
guilty
i can't give the definite like if you
just have to bet you have to bet 50 50
shot for all of them yeah 50 50 shot gun
to your head
man i gotta say not guilty okay i'll
tell you i and then we can all explain
but i am very iffy on it to be honest
with you because of how they're it feels
like they're digging for stuff it does
feel like they're doing this trial
with prejudice yes what you think 98 i'm
going to change answer that 98
where are you getting
i would like to bet you significantly
more than one dollar what's the over
under on you being an i don't
know pretty good
if i was a bad man i better
bet i bet himself yeah you know he's a
mudder so
i think that it's going to be not guilty
let me explain to you why also think
about it if something happens with the
ahmad arbory case where they find that
they're you know they get a lesser
sentence than people are wanting how
written house is not guilty
it's going to pop off in this country
you mean like 40 months yeah something
like that i have no idea
so i think not guilty let me explain to
you um why
uh
because no one likes black lives matter
anymore it's very different from before
the chaven trial people were afraid when
we did the uh you know black lives
matter is
a domestic terrorist organization in
antifa we did that in austin people were
shocked now most people to varying
degrees agree with that sentiment that
it's gotten out of control and it's
violent as a matter of fact before i go
because it was a sentiment they agreed
with until it became an extremist group
yeah well i think it was founded as an
extremist group and people followed it
not knowing so of course yeah
destruction when you start off when
you're jumping off point
is the destruction of the nuclear family
yeah yeah that's like if that's hard
that's your springboard you're going to
greg louganis yeah their manifesto is a
tough reason and your leaders are all
trained marxist and they say that yeah
so the polls now show that fewer
americans support black guys matter than
even in 2020. it was 61 in june 2020 48
percent now and of course we know with
those polls people tend to be afraid
they answer the yeah they either answer
in the way they think they will get in
the least amount of trouble or if people
are conservative they usually just don't
answer the phone what click yeah
uh more black americans oppose black
lives matter than uh in 2020. seven
percent now oppose them actively versus
four percent keep in mind that's a stat
where people go okay they're not really
opposing it but it's because it's tough
to have a black american opposed
something that has black lives matter in
the name the
the name they agree with i bet you if
you asked a lot of black americans about
the manifesto point by point and when i
did so they don't agree with that actual
manifesto because keep in mind 81 of
black americans support the same
at least as much as we have now or
increased police presence so in other
words black americans are vehemently
opposed to defund the police but then
they say they support black lives matter
so there's a disconnect there but
overall the sentiment has changed in
this country where people are fed up
with it and i think that that is
significant yeah it is significant we
also saw this in the virginia race where
he was getting a much larger share of
the black vote than people estimated
that he would right so their perception
of black lives matter may be skewed
because of the name but all of the
policies that back up conservative
principles are gaining traction yes they
are well especially with the working
class yeah across the board and not just
not just white working class all working
class there are games right now and you
know what let me just say one thing too
people give trump crap
and i i think they're i would like to
see some more patriots out there who
understand how many you know wins uh
donald trump racked up he
they were saying donald trump would have
won the general election i don't even
want to get into the whole idea of his
safest election whatever
because he focused on the culture wars
like if he just focused on the economy
actually no donald trump did take those
bullets so that you could have virginia
if donald trump didn't wage war against
critical race theory if you didn't shine
a light on the biased media you wouldn't
have other candidates who are able to
draft in behind him let's be honest
about it in virginia they wouldn't have
won those races if they just talked
about economics it was parents who were
pissed who were finally made aware of
what was being taught in their kids
schools they were finally being made
aware that they were being used as pawns
and it was a landslide
message that was being sent so when
people say oh you know donald trump lost
because he didn't focus no no no no we
are now allowed to discuss the things
that were only whispered on uh you know
right-wing echo chamber sites uh out in
public now so i think i think if nothing
else give him thanks for that before
donald trump yeah cnn was taken as a
legitimate news agency before donald
trump i was there when andrew breitbart
just to be clear andrew breitbart this
man i think it was uh what's his name
miss bell the professor at harvard uh
was it derek bell i don't know he was he
was a black liberation theologist
critical race theory this was before
barack obama was voted into office and
andrew breitbart was talking about how
dangerous it was yeah and racist and no
one paid attention matter of fact alec
baldwin would dismiss andrew breitbart
he dismissed the anthony weiner story
because andrew breitbart broke it alec
baldwin same guy you're thinking of same
guy murderer him
so i just want to be clear it was donald
trump who allowed that to be put onto a
main stage doesn't mean that i think he
was the best speaker doesn't mean that i
wish he wasn't more disciplined with his
tweeting but
give him a little bit of gratitude would
not be out of line here
[Laughter]
okay the man knew about bridges yes
yes he would never talk about a bridge
in the winter i look at the bridge and i
think i bet you we could we could streak
it gold
just a trump on it at least the lines
make the lines gold
gold lines in all american highways
good
we got enough gold for that right what
are you talking about come on man my
goal too
so add gold pencils you're a clown
pencils yeah i have a golden paper
strawberries
that's just what he's that's all he does
so that's the color
she remembers two things and says it
just thinks it's a thought
i was like like an improv exercise all
right what do you what what do you guys
want me to improv uh did i hear
starbucks and uh uh a clerk and people
like no we didn't say that starbucks and
clerk
everything he just thinks he's on who's
line all the time
did i win the points from drew
yeah well where's roy i love that black
fella that's saying that brady hmm put
him back in chains
what no yeah he does no you ain't you
ain't black you ain't black
wayne brady's like i know i don't know
if you're black i have to go by the
chains what why where are the chains
what you're back in them should you just
be locked in a kennel yeah what with
with with the marine dogs anyway what
okay
i don't want to go back to the kennel
put on put on the flea helmet oh come on
man so in kenosha right now uh just so
you know just so you see why people are
fed up this is happening in kenosha
anti-black lives matter protesters uh
clashed with black lives matter
protesters outside of the courthouse
which apparently is not an attack on
democracy here you go
there's dog the bounty hunter
that's where he is
do something man
[Music]
oh
he would be within his right when a man
tries to physically assault you
hey how many cars are you guys going to
finish tonight
tonight
hey i got something
oh here you go this one's hilarious
look at this dumpster right here
your mom was
so you know it's incredibly vulgar and i
believe it because we don't really the
context doesn't matter he refers to her
as a uh a receptacle put it this way yes
in there and we you know because we had
to deal with hecklers rosenbaum would
set her up
you know you are a dumpster for uh male
1 male deposits yes it's clear that's
when an idiot doesn't have a comeback
right well then she goes you are he goes
no it can't be you dumb and she keeps
using the c word she goes how she says i
don't have a vagina and she says without
skipping a beat you could swallow and
there's a pause where you see the moment
on it you just and then whips a sign and
she's smiling yeah you pointed that out
earlier she's like yeah she has a smile
on her face like yeah
let's see
let's see you dig your way out of this
one and uh instead he just gets violent
and commits felony battery instantly so
can we start playing at that clip again
and i want to pause it
look at this dumpster right here
your mom was hey i can't care
you are oh
no she's smiling
she's smiling she knows she got him and
here's the pause
she's still smiling look at her she's
like
oh what a little i feel like he's
wearing a little girl's backpack i know
he is too hey by the way the left are
the one they're the the party that
respects women yeah yeah absolutely oh
no clearly they're
they're non-violent that was a mostly
peaceful argument this was a mostly
peaceful argument mostly right until the
end yeah right up until he decided to
assault a woman
you can see the moment in his mind that
he's out of options verbally yeah he's
like i have been schooled
uh screw it throw the sign there's a
little voice in his bringer like throw
the sign throw the sign throw the sign
you can't look like a throw the
sign uh i hope he comes back up later to
get the sign and she won't let him have
it i hope he gets 42 months in a federal
penitentiary oh now that would be
wrong that's more violent than anything
the q anon shaman did who to be clear
not a fan of but still hope that guy
gets more time about he wasn't wearing a
horn hat no he wasn't wearing a horn hat
what an awful bunch of people i know i
know not a lot of them though no no not
her i'm encouraged by like there's
there's like three people there yeah it
is nice that there's just people kind of
giving up now yeah they're like you know
what this whole thing's ridiculous i'm
gonna go home until there's a verdict i
was told i could burn stuff yeah okay
maybe the sun's up let me just stop
letting the one percent of the one
percent dictate everything you do yeah
how about that how about let's not let
uh felons
dictate how we all behave okay so here's
what i wanted to go through here really
quickly too not quickly actually i want
to be thorough here
the argument that is being made now
they're spending a lot of time on this
with the verdict and uh mission control
will let me know is there any updates so
you guys can send in anything you can
tweet me
um
they're spending too much time on this
unfortunately but this is also because
the defense has sent sent over new video
and new images that was not submitted
for evidence right sorry the prosecution
the defense had not prepared for
so let me kind of explain to you at the
crux of
their latest argument which flies in the
face of their previous argument just to
be clear is this uh
non-digitally enhanced crystal clear
quality image of kyle rittenhouse here
we go bringing up allegedly aiming a gun
at somebody
okay
that's their cling
so uh just to be clear
they used amped
five software yeah to you know
improve the quality of that image as it
were and it says in the manual in amp
five software in the in the law
enforcement arena courts judges
prosecutors and defense attorneys can
sense the weakness of evidence and
exclude it if there is even a hint that
any manipulation has been done and then
they go on to say later if this is the
key evidence in a case the case is
likely to be lost that's in the manual
they could predict the future right and
you read the manual even a hint that any
manipulation has been done that's key
this is why we're talking about
a mistrial with prejudice
because
um
i don't know if you know this we use
this here at this this uh
this facility ourselves
handbrake is a video transcoder so
that's what so that's what would allow
you to change a file like the aspect
ratio of a video and to be clear let me
let me clarify why this matters
when you were listening yesterday um the
video file provided a defense it was not
only smaller with i believe a different
title than the image that you claimed
was 20 minutes later the aspect ratio
was changed
okay so you see that that's the aspect
ratio you know sometimes you watch a
film for people who don't know and you
have the black black bot you know
letterbox um
that's important because again the
manual says if there's even a hint that
any manipulation has been done so we
know the aspect ratio has changed and
thankfully some wonderful people on the
internet out there who love their
country uh noticed that krause for those
who don't remember mojo big fat uh big
fat
double prosecutor uh
had handbrake it's a video transcoder
the software on this computer there so
what we know is the manual says this
isn't reliable and if there's even a
hint of manipulation you're gonna get
this thrown out then you have the
defense saying well the image that we
got the file we've gotten is not even
the same the aspect ratio has been
changed and the prosecution's saying i
don't know how that happened while they
have software to specifically change the
aspect ratio yeah so so kraus made it
out to be like he wasn't a technical
genius right he's like yeah you know i
don't know i just hit send and i mean i
think it auto compress honestly whenever
i hit whenever i because i can't my
fingers it's pretty much like mashing
the keypad
i have a hard time dialing 9-1-1 every
time i have a coronary i just sort of ah
yeah about people with a lot of salt in
their diet probably just die yeah well
you know they're like i know
so uh
the aspect ratio is different the file
that the fence has is 3.6 megabytes the
states is 11.2 megabytes yeah that's a
big difference dimensions are totally
different so let me go out
that just tells me that this picture is
not is very likely not legitimate right
and it can't be admissible
that being said let's go through
what would be taking place in the
picture right based on these
descriptions and what you're looking at
and see if it even is plausible namely
that kyle written house is aiming his
rifle at somebody how he's aiming it and
how much time he would have had until
the very next high-def video that we
have showing his rifle in an entirely
different position let me show you let's
roll this clip the defendant comes
running in and drops the fire
extinguisher on the ground
he places it on the ground and then
raises his left hand to the gun and
points
this is what we see in the video
him putting the fire extinguisher on the
ground and then raising the gun
your honor i'm an object he's facing the
wrong direction
that's an argument
okay
he doesn't even rebut it
actually it's an argument like uh
that's an argument it's like yeah a good
one
hold on a second just hold your thoughts
i'm going to go aim this loaded gun at
the jury really quickly yeah finger on
the trigger crying out loud just in case
a little thing around
could tell me why that guy was wearing
gloves i have no i probably could
he's a big brain so here's the thing
there's no way i would argue
and i wish the defense had argued this
but they didn't have time to prepare for
it uh that kyle aimed his gun the way
they would have to take place in that
picture
and then
move
his gun was down
aimed down or aimed you know neutrally
uh with a right-handed
grip the entire every other video that
we have just to be clear every video
that we have but specifically right
after that image you're talking about
seconds after that image after you just
dropped the fire extinguisher they're
saying he aimed the gun seconds after
that this is how the gun is being held
here we go
look at that right there
right handed grip and the gun is aimed
down and while he's running
yeah right-handed grip left hand on the
barrel he may have had a second there i
just want everybody to understand that
he could have had a second running up on
zama but that's not enough time to do
this running up on zaminski seeing
someone a person that had allegedly with
a gun in his hand i'm going to go
through it yeah exactly kyle is
right-handed he wears a really tight
sling just to be clear let's bring up
these overlays it's a collage d3
so you can see that the sling is tight
now why does that matter okay um trying
things i only have like a piece of
string or something actually or rope i
was asking for one earlier
uh mine's in my shower
just ready to go just so we even have
video to reflect that where you can see
that the sling is very tight very taut
right there's tension uh roll clip c1
anthony huber hits written house with a
skateboard now look at how the gun as he
rotates
you can see the sling you can see the
sling there how it's tight right he
can't even the guy's trying to pull his
gun away he can't do it that's how far
the gun is taken from his body
which is almost none in other words he
has anyone out there who knows firearms
knows that you'll often have a sling
adjusted either you're carrying a sling
for long distances doesn't really matter
or if you're carrying it so that people
cannot take it from you or to assist
with recoil you're going to adjust the
sling so it's braced against your
shoulder yeah
uh so we see that time and time again
right-handed grip down and the sling is
tight now uh does someone have a string
something like that can someone out
there just bring me a string or a rope
really quickly before i show with the
rifle
you can get one is that what you're
saying someone really quickly just a
string or a rope guys uh in mission
control i'm looking around here
is this a cool there we go oh there you
go we got luna all right now why does
this matter i'm going to show you with a
rifle okay here's the moment in that
image yeah we have it there d4 you saw
it okay
um
here's a string okay okay
so the string is taught throughout that
image whenever it's against kyle's
shoulder and you see this in other
images right now why does this matter
this matters because look if the string
is taut that means it has to be at the
same pivot point
right that means oh sorry that means
here has to be against the shoulder
if this if it's not tight
the strings you're going to see this
right you're going to see well this is a
stiff string but you're going to see it
go down you're going to see it get some
slack there's no slack yeah in kyle's
fling at any point when the guy tries to
take the gun away from him it's still
touching his body and this shows you how
much
room there is that matters because it
makes it not impossible but very likely
impossible
allow myself to introduce myself yeah it
makes it
highly implausible yeah it makes it
absolutely impossible that he had to
clear malfunction with uh gross roots
and i'll explain that as well it makes
it completely impossible yeah so um just
to show you what i mean by this let's uh
let's uh uh do the uh demonstration
[Music]
okay so just so you know i'm gonna have
you guys come up and we've taken the
bolt out of the uh ar15 the bolt carrier
okay taking the charge and remove it out
so let me just have it everyone here so
you know that this isn't rust
can i uh sergeant arms here yeah
you want to bring this up here where am
i bringing this no no
oh the strap just came off this is a
wonderful start all right look just so
you guys can see can they see that
there's no bolt in here yes okay you
guys can see there's no there's no bolt
at all let me just clear this magazine
get rid of it put your finger in a
little deeper let everybody know there's
nothing in this magazine oh yeah yeah
from there
i'm sorry i'm trying to zoom in dude do
this camera here yeah show this guy
right on this camera oh better right
here right okay nothing in there
magazine out yeah so you can see brandon
nothing in here uh uh gerald can you uh
grab this too and tim just everyone
inspect it to make sure
because it's important that we use an
actual ar15 so you see the dynamics
there you go see it nothing in there see
nothing at all
nothing up must leave but they pulled
the wrong ar so
oh bullwinkle you're always misfiring
accidentally is this your full metal
jeff if you look in that gun
you'll find a projectile hopefully not
hopefully not though no
now just now
point that at the director the point
that the single point strike okay guys
so this is a single point strap the one
thing here is this is actually going to
be easier to do what they're claiming
kylo ren house did because this if you
see has a bungee cord an elastic which
is to to help you be able to do it to
help me be able to do the thing that
kyle wouldn't be able to do yeah as far
as we know he did not have a bungee on
his right a single point strap so uh
you saw that clip here's the thing he
came in and he had a fire extinguisher
now right if you look at that picture
can you bring up that picture again
bring up the picture uh another picture
of uh the pixelated picture where
they're claiming he really zoomed in
with the gun
okay the one that should freeze
the image right there you see that one
on the right
and that's why uh the defense said
you're doing it wrong that's very
clearly a left-handed grip yep okay so
now you can come back to me guys so you
see that look i'm gonna imitate exactly
what you are seeing there
is this
right right that's what you're seeing
bring up the picture again so people can
see me getting as close to what they're
claiming as possible
now why do you see that okay
this leg forward yep
this leg forward this hand is behind
this hand you can see it
if it's what they claim why part of his
elbow part of his arm his forearm is
covering the stock yeah okay
do we all agree
just like the defense and just like
forensic experts if that is in fact an
image and not just an artifact that that
would be how kyle has to be holding that
gun yeah
okay so we all agree no doubt now we all
agree that every single other time kyle
is carrying his gun
we see him with a right hand holding it
down or when he's running holding it
neutrally right right this is how he
always holds his gun this is how he shot
at it's not in question the whole day
every single person he shot he shot this
way right okay so what they are claiming
is you just saw him use that nalgene
bottle we have an actual fire
extinguisher and we have the footage of
cal written now it's running in right
putting down the fire extinguisher that
it's they could say it's an artifact but
we know that the fire extinguisher he
was putting out fires came around this
time okay so he would have put the fire
extinguisher down to be clear
so what does that mean left hand
occupied how would he have been holding
his rifle
he would have had to have been holding
it with his right hand
because according to binger according to
that asshat yeah he put the fire
extinguisher down here with his left
hand
now he aims the gun at zaminski
but he would have to switch again keep
in mind this is really tight
have to switch
to his left grip
aim the gun
and within how long do we have the
estimate within less than one second
while running keep in mind while running
play that footage again with his gun
down the one way one where you see him
in a sec a second later
right there okay so this is about
anywhere from what half a second yeah
half a second to a second later so aim
at zaminski according to that within
half a second while running switch this
around
this way to the point where he's already
running with it securely like this yeah
and assessing a threat that's coming up
from his right so he's got two threats
that he's keeping an eye on so we're
supposed to believe that within one
second kyle rittenhouse went from
right-handed grip
left fire extinguisher according to
banger
fire extinguisher goes down
switch and you guys can see even with
the sling it's really awkward to switch
switch grips well yeah switch it's
something you would do in a moment of
panic yes exactly yeah you would say let
me go to let me prepare myself so that i
can be weaker yeah usually yes i like to
use my uh my less uh my lesser hand yes
yes
i wanted to give them a running start
while he not shot them i mean you can
almost see too in the video that the
color of the gun is blending with the
car behind it like it's he's in the same
spot look there it already you can see
it yeah it's not even
in one sequence yeah there's no way this
is what we're supposed to believe kyle
written house boom fire extinguisher
comes in fire extinguisher down switches
from right hand
to left hand
brings it up and while running
less than a second to that next clip
while running switches
to this
for and for what purpose yeah like why
would he switch to his office why would
he switch to his offhand it makes no
sense no not at all also this is what i
was talking about with the charging
handle so for people who don't know
ar-15s
um we don't have it here but the
charging handle goes right there is uh
where should i uh can you zoom in i can
zoom in with this other camera this
camera right here in front of me so it's
an additional piece of awkwardness and
weight get closer not involved
okay right there so you guys can see
this we've removed like we said we
removed the bolt carrier here for people
who
don't know aren't familiar with an air
okay and i'm trying not to flag anybody
in here but there's no bolt carrier and
the charging handle is right here
now why does this matter
and i don't know guys that we can bring
back up uh we don't have this prepared
but the uh
uh not rosenbaum i forget the name the
blend together after a while
gabe um
yeah gage
okay
so gage claims also that kyle
cleared a malfunction or re-racked yeah
keep going yeah keep going that's here
right there right in between this guy
okay okay so yeah go right there okay so
hold on pause so gage claims that kyle
re-wrapped
this one i'm positive is not possible
and by the way do you know where this
came from keep it up there do you know
where this came from gage is twitter
yeah just so you know just him no one
corroborated it so right now okay hold
that pause but go back to me so right
now we have kyle written house okay
with his oh here you know what i'll show
it here yeah there you go yeah we have
him on his butt and you see right there
his hand is here yeah correct very clear
yes right hand is here now keep in mind
this is not like an ak or for example i
have a carbine rifle where you can
charge okay you can charge the gun for
example in an ak i believe it's around
here right you could charge it boom rack
it and you wouldn't see it right because
it would be obfuscated by the gun so
boom
effectively yeah an ar-15
you would have to
pull this back
now see how that changes the arm yeah
now to be clear
in the military the only way so bring up
that image again
the paused uh
video okay so he is sitting here aimed
this way can you put me in a form yeah
he's sitting here aimed this way okay
this sling is tight okay this thing is
tight against my shoulder you've already
seen that there's no slack in kyle
written houses sling when they try to
take his gun away the sling is tight
so in the marines they used to say you
know to keep this hand on here you would
rack uh or you were sorry you would
clear a malfunction by tap with a
magazine
rack bank you might use your left hand
the thing is they don't use their their
sling they don't have a tight sling yeah
right at that point they could have a
gun far away from them so my point here
is it's really difficult
for him to do it with his left hand if
he were to do with his left hand and
keep in mind how little time he had he
would have had to go over with his left
hand here clear this back
if there was some kind of a misfire keep
in mind there were no rounds that were
found that weren't spent yeah were
ejected so there's no evidence at all so
he would have had to
clear that either like this
which would be like it looks kind of
like a crossbow to people who use ar-15s
or be really difficult while this is
tight
in my shoulder to try and do it with my
left hand here very very awkward he
would have to do that in what a quarter
of a second and be back and shoot a
bicep no way yeah no way no i don't
think it holds up and the reason that
we're making such a big deal out of this
is that this is the linchpin this is and
this is what the judge was told was
telling him to be careful with yesterday
or uh yeah when they were talking about
it after the jury had been out and asked
for more evidence this is the thing
they're saying that he provoked the
entire thing and that would preclude him
from claiming self-defense what we've
just seen is at very best based on your
picture that gun was deported about
three feet above zaminski's head if it
was pointed at all right house makes the
very best yeah he would have missed by a
mile if he is if he was trying to do it
people do get a little jealous though
when you have a tight sling and a nice
rack yes
yes but then that's especially when you
re-rack it's like well that's like
rolling back the oh can't
give you a license plate why would you
do that no we can't get ball lifts how
many miles but then the guy who had
masked himself and hidden behind a car
comes out and he is now so let me just
put it this way if i point my gun at you
because i sense that you're a threat
does that give dave the right to chase
me down and beat me no no we've already
been through all that but what i'm
saying is now at their church yes first
off it is an illegitimate image that
should not be admissible and second the
case that's being made is is
not physically impossible but certainly
less likely than uh oj not being able to
fit that glove put it that way yeah i
gotta say the case you just made makes
it pretty impossible i'm just pointing
out that i think the uh lawyer should
watch this show
they don't even have their defense down
well they didn't have time to prepare
for it no that's true i mean that's why
they're trying to so this last minute
yeah they edited that why would they
edit the aspect ratio and send it over
we just wanted to make sure that you you
know you had it in 4k
i can almost by dropping the resolution
right somebody put up the that guy the
the heftier one is the principal from
beavis and butter yeah
i was laughing so hard but that is what
he looks like that's all i want yes
but i i kind of believe that they would
have done that out of stupidity like i
do believe that there might just be a
complete ignorance without sending that
over and that's not expected that when
he aimed a loaded gun at the gym that's
what i mean like you look at him and
you're like hold on i don't know if this
is the best
we've been investigating the wrong
people it does appear this man aimed a
loaded firearm in an unsuspecting jury
what do we do here
my job's no longer required he also
thinks that he casually set down a fire
extinguisher did the old switcheroo with
this gun yeah i re-racked it and uh then
killed a pedo wait a moment
bye god what's and i've got it
yes
they retired
just to clarify that was not a loaded
weapon in the courtroom but he didn't
know that for sure um and uh no you're
gonna just grab a piece of evidence
yeah so it's evidence you don't know
what it did like what if he just grabbed
like cocaine in a drug trial
this is the stuff he would have taken a
bump like
oh that was real advice
oh no jerry stop moving so fast oh this
is the right here not guilty yeah
you're on the other side wait i don't
care
let me go out there and see if any of
those protesters have any of that uh
super fentanyl
i hear it's being made in the lab and
stabbed into people at concerts yes by
the way hey while we're talking about
firearm safety sponsored by walther boom
here at lottery with crowder go to
waltherarms.com
uh you know we don't have any sponsors
on this show you can find a dealer near
you at walther arms.com you can't buy
firearms online obviously at from
directly from the site you can buy them
from brokers online where they would
ship it to an ffl but
i just carry walls just so you know i
carried them before they became a
sponsor i always carried revolvers and
the only semi-autos that i liked were
walters because they just fit so well
and being a revolver guy the triggers
are nice so i just some and they said
yeah sure we have the balls to sponsor
your shows cause the other guys are
scared they're like we don't care like
great you're my first choice anyway so
here's what i just say go to the dealer
a gun dealer near you gun gun store try
it usually i have ranges try the walther
see if you don't prefer it i've never
met a single person who does not prefer
it to
the brand x by the way make horrible
firearms brandex that's you never want
to buy that you can get that out of a
trunk of a of uh of a car yeah they're
nothing like that pdp that i have that's
fantastic oh my gosh that's so nice
i love my mtv and just i've never been
aroused by an inanimate object before
well
you haven't
okay oh sorry
i made a velvet couch when i was young
whoa
i just used to sit there
watching captain planet and i would find
myself getting very comfortable it's
like crushed velvet yeah an old buick
start actually crushed like the irish
mobster car okay well that'll do it
really fast we have an update outside
the courthouse this is from hillary
mintz who's a reporter for the local
channel uh the abc wisconsin affiliate
hearing reports that the kenosha sheriff
arrested someone for following jurors on
a bus claimed to be from nbc or msnbc
though a credentialed member of the
network has to identify a photo said he
doesn't work for either we're working to
confirm more details it's just chris
it's just lawrence o'donnell yeah
[Laughter]
i was confusing chris hayes and lawrence
with donald i almost said chris
o'donnell i don't see him since batman
and robin like
i think
i can't imagine how bad that is yeah i
can't imagine uh that person should be
arrested yes they said that they weren't
right that show should be
i don't mean just like putting the drunk
in the drunk tank yeah really i mean
they should be they should be put in
where they're putting the q and on
shaman honestly instead i want to send a
message like you cannot intimidate
jurors like this this is a problem this
derails the entire justice system if you
let this happen if juries can just be
intimidated with prejudice yeah there's
going to happen now it's got to be a
mistrial with prejudice at this point if
they tried to arrest some of the jurors
well here's my question now so can you
bring that tweet back up there token
owen so it says that this is at least
one juror who was followed is that what
they're saying yes they were following
the bus following the fox soldiers onto
the bus for following jurors on the bus
so that's plural
that's plural yeah how many jurors have
been compromised right i think it's it's
a you know six degrees of of jurors in
this trial it's really easy oh we know
this person we know that okay you can
track him down it's it's a problem and a
lot of these people are afraid to do the
right thing because they also don't want
to lose their ability to make a living
they don't have to put their family in
protection we used to only have to put
mobsters
who snitched in witness protection yeah
you're going to do that because of black
lives matter and antifa with jurors and
then they would be killed in witness
protection because we didn't do a very
good job no we didn't well we didn't
except with sammy the bull yeah yeah he
was just in arizona and he's like i
guess i'll sell ecstasy now yeah
and no one suspected and they're like uh
hey
who you're
yes what is funny sammy the bull what's
funny is every one of his neighbors were
like did you see that sammy the bull
just moved in here yeah it wasn't even
like a low profile area it was like a
suburb hey yeah my name is don yeah it's
not sam samuel hey mr uh uh sam or mr
bull hi i don't know what you prefer
just wanted to bring you some sugar and
say welcome to the neighborhood you
my name's jackie the bull uh mcdonald's
yeah yeah how you doing yeah my family
uh my name is uh
my name is donda steer yeah you want to
roll on some orange pikachu or i hurt
your face yeah yeah yeah yeah
lightly
[Laughter]
are you a native arizonian my whole
life
morning bread born and read right here
in phoenix yeah
you like the new uh you like the uh the
new stuff i put out the pillars the
columns yeah yeah yeah hey
angel boy
lionhead uh that lionhead fountain cost
me two million dollars which i earned as
you know as a grocery clerk at the local
piggly wiggly yeah
i ain't never killed 22 people no no no
no no shirt says born and raised in
brooklyn what what's
what don't worry about it but you just
well hey don't worry about it don't read
my shirt yeah what are you doing mr nosy
nose over here reading my shirt what's
next huh you're going to be uh you're
going to be reading my bank statements
get out of here looking at my shirt hey
eyes up here your car has new york place
let's go for a ride let's go for a ride
yeah let's go yeah you know what i like
that you notice my plates yeah you're
like oh you know i get closer yeah hey
you want to get closer to the trunk how
about in it shut your mouth
now i'm going to shoot into the trunk
like a good native arizonian wood
but seriously what do we have to put
jurors under witness protection yeah
that's ridiculous you're gonna have to
this is this is not justice this is mob
rule and this is why it's important and
i'm going to get to the q and champ q
anon shaman in a little bit
this is why it's important people say
we're we are not a democracy we're a
constitutional republic you need to
understand that now that does not mean
that there is no democratic process in
this country the founding fathers
understood that democracy was mob rule
you understand that democracy pure
democracy when people say well we don't
really live under pure capitalism well
that's true but i'm not really arguing
that we need to live under completely
entirely pure capitalism we do have
legitimate purviews of government to
make sure people are playing by the
rules things like antitrust laws so when
people say that it's like oh we're just
changing the definition of words well
you need to understand that democracy
pure democracy means mob rule just means
people vote and uh we want to keep
slaves
most people want to keep slaves we would
have never added slavery if it was pure
democracy women would have never gotten
the right to vote it was a pure
democracy
the men who voted for women have the
right to vote
you're welcome
yeah
and by the way we're sorry
yeah we really shouldn't have let you
yeah it was a bad bad call
i mean you know up until it's like you
know we gave you the right to vote
centuries of well we're all decades of
screwing up and then virginia now okay
you're making up some some ground was
like lindbergh like you give it a shot
amelia oh she's not coming back and they
voted in it where'd she go it was more
like the hindenburg
so
uh thanks for hillary
if they only knew
someone's like i don't like the show
until you say
i know i don't know it's not funny by
the way when i call hillary clinton a
it doesn't mean i'm calling all
women no it's very specific very
specific barely even a woman and if you
are acting as though it is not a
descriptor that you have used in your
private life
i don't trust you you've also never sang
a rap song from the 90s no no i'm
talking about specifically hillary
clinton that's how you would describe
her you also don't have coffee can
ankles yes
what a gross woman
those are
i mean beautiful beautifully i didn't
mean gross in a bad way it was our
telephone game with string yes
i'm sorry you're speaking to one ankle
hello hello oh i can hear you it's all
right
hollow your husband calls off
from work duty on epstein island yes
exactly okay so look let's go to the q
and on shaman here and i want to know
what you guys think uh and we'll see if
we have any more updates on the trial
you're playing they don't make them like
they used to on mug club
so jacob chansley is the guy's name
uh he was just sentenced to 41 months in
prison jacob doesn't quite sound like
you a non-shaman guy he's not a good guy
as i'm trying to say i don't want a
sherpa named jacob yeah
i want to get to the top of the
himalayas ah yeah ask skyler he's got it
for you
i want to get to the top of bs
conspiracy
thank jacob if you name your kids skyler
just go to hell yeah exactly well i
think they are
so
no offense the guy never committed a
violent crime regardless of where you
line up yeah and you know what let me
clarify the reason that i don't like
this guy
is because
uh
well everything but it's because he then
blamed donald trump
for doing stupid stuff so he went out
there he's been an idiot he's been
seeking fame his whole life he doesn't
do his due diligence he le he's latched
on to every other stupid conspiracy
theory and then he said ah trump made me
do it i think that's cowardly so i don't
dislike him for the reason that a lot of
other people dislike him i'm just not a
huge fan that being said he isn't even
being accused of committing a violent
crime 41 months in prison also he's on
camera just to be clear
on camera when they were allowed into
the capitol
telling people to be peaceful here you
go
[Music]
one
other show you understand yeah
tom hanks
that's my pipe rack yeah
one not to come in here yeah he's not
supposed to delicious prison sex i still
don't understand furloughs either what
what you should either be in prison or
you shouldn't so let's be uh clear here
he pled guilty to obstruction of an
official proceeding which carries a max
20 years of imprisonment which also
sounds ridiculous three years of
probation potential fine of 250 000
he's not even being accused of a violent
crime we're looking at over three years
in prison now let's compare that
to molotov cocktails and by the way do
we we have the updated montage here
right yeah just to be clear when people
talk about january 6th is the most
violent day in history and they well we
obviously know that's not true right
because people were murdered right
cities were burned down to the ground i
mean just kenosha is a stronger example
but then they realize well they say well
no it's because it's the capital and
it's emblematic of you know our
democracy and so they well then i
realized no wait a second they bombed
courthouses and i don't know if you guys
remember this they tried to storm the
white house as well
so they did let's just compare what q
and shaman did remember be peaceful
what was that
come on
you sound like you're doing any smoking
commercial
i used to protest and inside
i would do it again
and
yeah this guy i love how they always
give you a fine of 250 thousand dollars
but then you can't work yeah i know no
well you know good luck and that guy
clearly has a quarter million i hope he
enjoys the salt mine so
let's compare what he did and you see on
camera and the prison sentence versus
molotov cocktails gas bombs destroying
courthouses and trying to take the white
house
mostly peaceful
oh my god
it's a portland courthouse
oh
oh looks like st john's church is on
fire the parish office uh we went
downstairs and it is on fire there's
definitely a fire here
this is at the white house they were
trying to kick down the fence in there
remember just to be clear
let's just be very clear about it they
weren't invited in
well now let's also compare so
over 40 months in prison for
trespassing effect what amounts to what
a kid's skateboarding on private
property does let's be clear about it uh
and maybe a a a party not even drunk not
even drunk and disorderly it's
disorderly so let's compare that with
antifa black lives matter you have
olivia van norman interfering with the
police officer disorderly conduct was
caught and released john colin hacker
felony robbery caught and released
daniel christoph christophe marion dui
assault trespassing catch and release
tyler benjamin uh union uh disorderly
conduct felony rioting catch and release
and by the way this guy the q and on
shaman just to be clear it's one thing
if you're non-violent it's another thing
if you're completely non-violent with a
weapon on premises where it would be
prohibited wouldn't be allowed to carry
guns into the state capitol
um
he didn't have a weapon he didn't even
have a weapon so what do they do they
claim that his flag post
was a weapon
oh my god what is this the patriots even
though he didn't use it violently also
hey where have we seen people accusing
those who they disagree with of a flag
post is all of a sudden a weapon i feel
like we've seen this
i mean i like the sign
now look at this breaking my sign
[Applause]
now watch what they do
he's got a ball staff he's trained i
hate everything i don't understand how
they can give this guy that kind of
sentence oh i do no i mean seriously
well why are we on the side of the
people that wanted to destroy fbi doj
they are not on your side people no why
are they not why
like when it comes to the capital when
it comes to their own public buildings
everything because of the narrative well
i know it's not because of the narrative
the scared people are a controllable
people they don't want people it's the
same reason that garland lied about them
adding a security tag next to parents
protesting critical race theory to be
flagged down as terrorists
how many by the way how many people have
been killed
at pta meetings
um this week yeah
how about this year at all how about
from anyone who protests none okay
several dozen of these riots yeah all
right i think we're done i think we're
done with this conversation it's not
that they care
about your security it's they want you
dependent on them for security let's
disarm the population and let's make
sure that they know the feds are in
control and hey by the way call the cops
but don't call the cops because they're
all racist so i don't know no look let
me remind you that 37 of those people in
january 6 are still being held in jail
as of september okay
and no catch and release program no
catching they don't treat them like fish
they're just the ones who are violent
treat them like fish that they eat i
guess yeah as long as it's not too fishy
like tilapia it's white and flaky now
according to us marshals um
this is from the u.s marshals now uh and
this was also reported at cnn they've
also been held in conditions uh with for
no violent crime some of these people
worse than serial killers in one dc jail
the they shut off the water for multiple
days
toilets were clogged inmate was sprayed
with pepper spray not allowed to wash it
off and it got into the vents uh food
has been served cold congealed which
really doesn't matter all that much
because at that point honestly they shut
off your water cold food is the least of
your problems yeah throwing that in
third is kind of weird yeah you're not
gonna be able to make any toilet wine
yeah they they burn me with pepper spray
and
uh i gotta tell you the mashed potatoes
almost freezing they're almost it's
tasteless
now it was it's been so bad that judge
royce lambert even ordered one of the
inmates who had cancer ordered into
another jail and then released because
they weren't allowing him to get his
cancer treatment so keep in mind what
i'm saying here is when people say uh
this is a this is a an uprising right
this is an incitement this is uh what's
the other term they use uh insurrection
correction
sorry sorry uh erection i was getting
confused
they were protesting your riots at the
place where you're supposed to have a
protest right yes exactly and never in
the history had people come in and
actually breach the grounds and either
sit in back in the 70s happened almost
every single day or in wisconsin for the
teacher's bill right do you remember
that they literally came in and took
over the state capital right look i i
were arrested and put in jail for years
yeah scott walker how many yeah probably
zero yeah i think the shaman is awful
and should be in prison just for his
personality but but he really shouldn't
be right nobody did look people need to
be able to separate do you think the
guy's a guy's a goofball yeah do you
think he made some bad decisions of
course should he be treated worse than
violent criminals who've bombed
buildings of course not no and should
people be held with with really
forfeiture to their rights yeah with no
convictions at this point in conditions
worse than serial killers had
no absolutely not and if we can't find
when people talk about common ground
let's get rid of this idea of common
ground because i have to agree how about
just empathy for people who didn't
commit violent crimes who've been in
jail for months and had their water shut
off how about some empathy we've talked
about having empathy for you know people
who don't get a fair shake who come from
bad neighborhoods i'm just talking about
some empathy for what is right you just
say ah my side your side you see this on
the left all the time oh it's so uh so
tribal really well you wanna you wanna
do away with the prison system but
you're doing an end zone cheer because
someone can be a political prisoner for
non-violent crimes on camera saying be
peaceful
for over three years because you don't
like his face paint
don't tell me you want to find middle
ground common ground don't tell me
you're moderate
you don't care this is what i'm saying
the mob you're seeing the same thing the
mob is the proxy of tyranny and you're
seeing and by the way one side wants to
use the mob
one side wants to consistently use the
mob across cities
in courthouses across this country they
want to affect
juries verdicts yeah
do you want to know what this looks like
in the future if you don't check
something like this and it five years
ten years down the road just look at
russia look at putin controls the state
media intimidates people and puts
political prisoners in prison after
stealing their fortunes
and giving it to his buddies yeah and
then tries to have them killed in a way
that looks somewhat accidental i mean
poison that's you know on the tip of it
yeah exactly right some i said somewhat
dave they don't put a ton of effort into
killing it yeah they don't mind
just saying they're trying to achieve
the goal and kind of go oops and look
there's i would be lying to you if i
didn't say there was a part there was
not a part of me that laughed when the
russian band riot was imprisoned
yeah because how do you think that was
going to end but i still think it's
wrong like that is funny punk rock song
now tell me joke about life in ghoul
lake
[Laughter]
knock knock who's there not you oh
go like you disappear no one ever see
you again oh you're a real riot what do
you say now what do you say now hope you
enjoy siberia that's it very cold
hold on i have to call best friend
advisor yes
rock in the cold yes that is what you
have forever this is this is where we
are by the way i think right now they're
uh probably the jury is probably
watching some video or something if
they're not allowing anything to not on
a bus that's going
80 miles an hour let's try with
prejudice right that's absolutely hey
let me ask you this right now if they
have some national guard deployed in
wisconsin
genuine question comment oh by the way
if you're watching on youtube please
smash that like button we've been doing
a lot this week if you want us to come
back with the verdict
uh smash the like button otherwise we're
gonna just we'll be gone it'd be a shame
if we didn't have the verdict be a shame
if we didn't have the verdict
yeah
i mean yeah did you see my uh did you
see my old cadillac coupe deville
yeah
it's the perfect car for a z
yep
arizona plates
should have caught that one the orange
state
no no no no it's not don't argue with
sammy the bull so
he's out too yeah i know yeah and i know
sammy that bull is out it's also five
five i want to meet him she's a fan of
the show
he's watching right now laughing his ass
off i'm alright sammy he's like yeah
these guys are talking about me right
now no i'm gonna go hurt him yeah i've
got to go hurt him because
that's how i treat the ones i love
i didn't mean to kill the rabbit george
what's interesting about sammy though
not that we have to get into that but
god he was going to kill him that's kind
of why he ratted otherwise he would have
been a normal you know that normally
sometimes though you just have to take
your beating just listen to krauss
that's what he said well yeah take your
let me ask you this genuine question
before i leave okay
does anyone out there including anyone
who's moderate do you really believe
that national guardsmen are deployed in
wisconsin because of they're worried
about white supremacists white
supremacist uprisings
in wisconsin no
i feel like god no no no they're not
worried look and i'm saying take an
extremist group that they've tried to
paint all conservatives with like you're
all white supremacists okay
they're not it's an on issue no one's
actually afraid of it no one's concerned
you've never had to prep a city for ed
furlong and ed norton showing up in
their bomber jacket burning down cities
there's like five in the country they're
like westboro baptists and by the way
whenever someone says white supremacists
at this point are racist to the people
on the right i think there's enough
evidence at this point where a counter
how about this you just call them
pedophiles liberals are pedophile they
say you're racist you have a pedophile
why because you support pedophiles right
you got bill clinton yeah you got
epstein you've got rosenbaum every
single time the professors the
professors
who support maps
minor attracted people i don't think we
need a less offensive term for
pedophiles if there's ever been a group
of people who do not require
a less offensive term it's pedophiles as
a matter of fact i only use the word
pedophile because i can't sandwich child
rapist in the word i have to hyphenate
it i prefer dr kid lover yes doctor kid
lover well really it's the same thing
it doesn't matter
doctor no means yes there you go how
about this
end it with this right now we're going
to go to mug club dave's going to be in
naples florida here yes they call you
racist they call you white supremacists
for believing that jurors shouldn't be
doxed or people have the right to defend
themselves from now on we refer to
democrats whenever they pull out the
racist card as pedophiles as child
rapist supporters i think it's silly and
childish but there's more evidence for
it than anyone in this room being racist
youtube you can piss off you pedophile
supporters